alors oui oui je les trouve très sympa
qu'il y ait très sexy non pas se
maintenir
maxime là j'ai un petit peu connue parce
que on sait chevaucher un petit peu je
cochais utilisation non anglo oui trés
bonne recrue il y avait des excès
d'entre eux je crois que s'ils craignent
ils pas sûr de revenir l'année prochaine
peut-être je peux te conseiller
christophe beaugrand ça donnerait un
petit peu de d'humour et de jeunesse
admission mon meilleur moment dans tpm
paix je crois que c'est l'olympia
d'avoir eu la chance de faire l'olympia
a demandé aux personnes et pouvoir faire
un skate lorsque je ne savais pas où je
rentrais sur celle ci que derrière il y
avait un écran qui disait quand fallait
rire ou pas rire mes blagues bon pc pas
là ça m'a aidé en plus ça m'a soutenu
mais c'était ça le meilleur - un côté ce
moment j'en ai plusieurs
mais je les garde pour pour les passer à
l'antenne direct parce que
accumulez pic mais je t'aime quand même
[Musique]